okay good afternoon and welcome to berk
auditorium for today's savings serious
lecture at the Yale School of Forestry
environmental studies my name is john
d'agostino and i'm happy to introduce
today's panel discussion on
Connecticut's innovation ecosystem to
those of you in the audience or listing
at home welcome the saban sustainable
venture prize and speaker series are
organized by the Yale Center for
Business and the environment through the
generous support of the agent Andrew
save and Family Foundation the Sabin
pries itself is a
twenty-five-thousand-dollar award to the
top student and faculty for profit
ventures advancing a more sustainable
world so with that I will turn it over
to today's moderator Ben Berkowitz CEO
and co-founder of see click fix a new
haven grown startup and leader in
government 2.0 technology cool thank you
thanks for having me and thanks for
thanks for coming out during during fine
I'll stay here so we have Derek cook who
is a graduate of the Kellogg School of
Management he runs independent software
here in New Haven and as a key
contributor to the growing Connecticut
ecosystem he also as a manager of what
is known as the grid which is New
Haven's new innovation hub that's going
to be launching soon and we have Tim
coats will be joining us shortly but
Casey Pickett is a graduate of fes and
som and is the director of innovation
for the state of connecticut department
of economic and Community Development
where he makes Connecticut a better
place for young innovative companies
door tries or trice might rise he's
helped us so I can testify to this so
the to frame the conversation for the
next hour so we're talking about
Connecticut's growing entrepreneurial
community my company has been here for
kind of about four years as a company
and
I've really seen it take off especially
in New Haven we're talking specifically
about why community local community
matters to entrepreneurs to folks
growing their tech company as their
businesses and how an active community
of entrepreneurs can support additional
information how do you use this network
to grow your venture and how do we build
the community together in Connecticut
that really pushes us ahead and into the
future so I will say I am definitely
biased towards New Haven I I came here
by way of Yale but not the university I
came through the hospital by the way my
mother I grew up in westville I went off
to George Washington University and I
came back after four years there and
decided that I would really commit to
this town and I've had I think a really
good run at growing my business here it
has been a place where we have had
phenomenal access to talent on the
engineering side on the business side on
the marketing side we've had phenomenal
support from the local government the
state government community members and
its really been a place where there's
enough enough interesting to inspire you
but not too much to distract you and
it's been a really great place to focus
so i guess with that Tim ol some will
get here when he gets under my parachute
okay cool yeah you can I could see that
it's a habit then can I pause you just
yeah yeah you're curious how many people
in the audience are developing a venture
through the Sabin and Sobotka prize
system
thanks you're cool so we why don't we
jump in with some questions I have I
have nine or ten questions for these
guys and then feel free to just raise
your hand and shut me up whenever shut
them up and jump in if you want so why
does community matter it's entrepreneurs
I mean if you don't mind I'll please
I'll start out so community matters
mostly because it solves problems that
entrepreneurs face startups require an
incredible amount of resources in the
form of capital and a lot of the things
that been already touched on so I think
he's already exposed you to the the
answer city and state support you know
communities of customers beta users
being an entrepreneur can be a really
lonely road so actually even having
emotional support from people who are
your peers is incredibly important and
you probably experienced this in in your
program as well it's not not unlike
preparing for midterms or finals every
day so that's what I would say that's a
good analogy right i mean it's it is
like working on a really hard problem
for a class that is just easier to do if
you have access to other smart people
have see the problem differently and can
bring in other ideas an idea is a
network itself and any new idea is a
combination of a couple of existing
ideas and that that spark that connects
new ideas into some new combination can
either happen inside of one person's
head but seems more often to happen in a
coffee shop or in a study group and get
written down on the back of a napkin
it's just easier to have great ideas
when you've got a lot of other smart
people around thinking up cool ideas
yeah it also helps have access the
multiple refrigerators if you find
yourself low on cash and the final judge
decides whether you eat or not that it
usually helps to have a partner who has
a full refrigerator or
patent crashing and I only say that half
jokingly it's it can be quite quite
grueling and demanding so yet definitely
helps to have a co-founder partners but
even people outside your company you
just are rooting for you who really want
you to succeed I think Ben's you know
one of the reasons that you know Ben's
company succeeded is they've done a
phenomenal job of attracting just a
great community of people who care about
what SeeClickFix does and yeah that's
what I startups all about engaging
people in what you're doing and getting
them to care at the end of the day
having friends who understand that
sunday-dinner is ramen noodles this is
important i guess or it's sunny
breakfast right so what do what are you
guys doing specifically with your
organization's individually in New Haven
to build community well so I could start
we're we've been doing actually quite a
bit and Ben's been involved a lot of
entrepreneurs have been involved and I
think that's really important that any
kind of community can be built by lots
of people but the entrepreneurs really
do have to take a leadership role
because they actually know what they
need they know what other entrepreneurs
need so they do a lot better job of
creating the kind of structures and
support that will work but in New Haven
we've been working for gosh probably you
know between three and four years on the
idea of how to build up vibrant startup
community and we're entering a new phase
with the the state's public private
partnership CT next the innovation
ecosystem but you know a lot of the
things we've been doing come down to
individual connections finding out how
we can help it one person I think
anybody who's ever built a community
probably been included I think
recognizes that well you can use social
media you can use events you need to be
very consistent in your your approach in
building community that at the end of
the day it comes down to individual
relationships and I think that's a great
segue to our most recent participant
here Tim coats so we're surprised if I
thought your conan by parachute that
would have been awesome drop right in hi
everybody sorry Emily ok traffic Iran's
at you from Hartford tim is the managing
director of CT next initiative to
strengthen cts innovation ecosystem he
has master's in public policy that I got
the acronym right now yuh from Harvard
Kennedy School and we were we're just
picking these guys brains about what
they are doing as individuals and
organizations to build community in New
Haven I'll jump to you Derek we need to
make sure to get back to you have to
talk about startup weekend before we get
off this topic I think as well okay cool
awesome you have thoughts on that what's
what's the question examples of things
that we're doing to build community
around the state Derek's talking about
New Haven yet that's on the other yeah I
think so I mean it's it's interesting I
think the way that I think about this is
the state's trying to do we are trying
to marry systems Sol system of
entrepreneur support so if we think
about education and it's and you've all
got gotten a grade 1 and grade 2 and
grey three entrepreneurs go through a
very similar type of a staging and so
you've got people who are starting with
my concept and a thought they get they
then have an idea that gets formed into
something more sophisticated and they
can and they in and they go staging you
got I don't run it I don't a run and
talk at the same time exactly for the
for this reason medium and so we're we
have this very systemic approach to
helping support entrepreneurship and I
think the other piece of all this is is
in also making sticky communities and so
how do we layer that systemic approach
with this out with is real grassroots
opportunity so I think from where I sit
looking at all these all these
innovation hubs across the state and if
you guys talked about that
so the way a this this whole this whole
projects organized is that there are
four innovation hubs New Haven being a
New Haven being one of them Stanford
Hartford in stores being the others and
so we've got people just like Derek in
each of these other communities not
quite another Derek stature Thank not at
their extension but also quite good the
and so really what our effort is ha how
do we build statewide communities
amongst these up amongst these leaders
in in each innovation hub and so one of
the things we've been doing is um is
hosting monthly meetings just to share
best practices and also to think about
how do we build that system together and
so those I think from where I said it's
really one of the things that we're
doing it so Tim and Eric are operating
at somewhat different levels Derek is
the manager of the grid which is the
effort to create a hub of innovation in
New Haven amp up what's already
happening here innovation hub is an
aspirational term the idea is that we
layer enough entrepreneurial activities
training competitions mentorship
education events so that eventually New
Haven and these other places Stamford
hartford stores get known locally as
hubs of innovation so it's an
aspirational term but derek is working
to create this local network and he's
layering up layers of activities tim is
working with all four of those
innovation hub efforts to create
community among all of the Derrick's and
all the other people that Derek is built
around him so that there are lots of
difference from interlocking communities
and tim is engaging that that bigger
network of networks is over yeah I just
just a plug for the importance of Tim's
row I it's important that entrepreneurs
lead communities like this but one of
the things that is true is that an
entrepreneur might go off and for
example start something like
make Haven like series of entrepreneurs
did and in may cave in New Haven just
recently a makerspace that's incredible
it's getting a lot of traction but a lot
of those entrepreneurs have businesses
that they're running so one of the
problems with communities like this is
if the entrepreneurs are out there doing
a lot of great crazy stuff sometimes it
is a lot of one-off it doesn't generate
a lot of community so the idea of
creating structure and some consistency
and repeatability is actually really
really important if you want to develop
a community over 10 years that become
something you know great may not be like
Silicon Valley exactly it might be its
own a unique thing but it's repeating
itself it's it's creating itself
continually and it doesn't require kind
of as much active management so the
structural piece and what Tim's doing is
really really key and I think what's
interesting to it's really so I'm a
policy person and when we think about
how how do we solve really difficult
problems we're not any one organization
can help solve that problem by itself
you've got to have all these different
people really bringing bringing their
minds bring their energy to that issue
and then trying to figure out well how
do we all connect on this problem to
make sure that we're actually solving it
because if we forget all these different
factors that we don't see because we're
really nearly focused on I've only got
kind of bioscience or I've only got up I
guess pretty seed funding there's stages
on that on that continuum that get
missed and so really wanting to make
sure that our case and I said at a
30,000 foot level and each of each of
those different stages is a one taken
care of but then to also how do we make
sure we keep on on getting better at
supporting that so I make a t-shirt it
says New Haven it's better than your
town if I had a choice I would not think
outside of the geopolitical boundaries
of our city however running a business I
have had to think that way see click fix
has really had the benefit of attracting
talent from around the state and
and out of state and getting folks to
move here but we have folks that commute
from West Hartford and and other other
parts of the state how do we how do we
think about new haven in the context of
the state i mean aside from you know
these these various you know Derek's
counterparts and other parts of this
state but you know there's a lot of
talent hiding inside these really boring
insurance companies and sports networks
and and they're awesome and some of them
work for us now I think it's a
tremendous opportunity and people are
always I think very shocked when they
find out that like there is talent that
exists in Connecticut outside of New
Haven how do we help people girlfriend I
think that that's exactly from a from a
design or policy perspective a lot of
the research that we were doing to
figure out how to bolster the existing
efforts around creating more vibrant
entrepreneur communities in Connecticut
you know when you go and check out
Boston and New York what you find is
that in Boston is the attack and
entrepreneurship capital of new england
the north east until bloomberg started
ramping up the new york stuff but it's
not just that it's not that it's boston
and it's not even that it's cambridge
it's seven square blocks that make up
Kendall Square that's ground zero of
entrepreneurship in the whole northeast
and it's basically all concentrated
there and everybody wants to be and
every smart persons that are looking for
all the other smart people and the
forces of agglomeration draw people
together so when you try to take that
lesson and apply it to Connecticut where
we have is it six cities with over
100,000 or over something but but not
under we've got to this incredible
dispersion of people and a whole bunch
of small cities and 169 towns what's the
system architecture
that will help people access these these
networks easily it's not it doesn't feel
easy to get anywhere in Connecticut even
though when you overlay Silicon Valley
over connecticut they're about the same
size and people don't have a problem
driving 45 minutes in Silicon Valley
what they do here so what does that mean
but we we were worried about was
developing a system in which you know
we've got a little bit of money to use
to blow on these sparks as a state and
169 towns are going to say right here i
am the place and we'd end up with you
know eight or fifty innovation hubs the
alternative wornall Turner was well New
Haven is the most organic deep you know
body of entrepreneurship in the state we
could just dump it all there and let's
do it one hub that clearly wasn't going
to fly either politically or because of
the structure of Connecticut's
population the fact that innovation
actually is spread pretty widely around
the state so we ended up at a for now
model of four hubs relatively spread
throughout the state but it's it's an
ongoing question what is the right
architecture to engage a state and how
does each town relate to the other towns
around it that's Amelia stabbed about
for like recruiting purposes though Orca
network you know for these guys I mean
they get out of school they want to
start a company here then you're looking
for a co-founder employee number one I
don't I don't know that I would know
what network to go through besides
craigslist which I mean we've used and
there's a lot of talented people hanging
out on craigslist some other people
hanging out on craigslist also i should
be careful
you know we we really really leverage
our own network and this point our own
community which is not geographically
located or tied to a geography but I I'm
not sure I'd know how to how to find
that talent outside a new heaven and
bring them in because I think I mean I
think that's really important I this is
like Derek and I are on like this thing
this Kendall Square thing like nine
square is going to be Kimmel square I
hate to tell science park that but it's
just true it's it's going to be I mean
it's it's got that right focus and it's
really small and it's got the right vibe
for being that kind of thing that it's
going to take over science parks right
yeah exactly spiritually not join reg
squares so what are you doing about
about town so so actually before we get
to talent one of the things that and
it's kind of related but one of the
things that been kind of prompted me on
earlier with startup weekend so you know
this this idea of politically and
geographically we've got kind of
boundaries that we think about is it's
important in some ways but it's kind of
unimportant in other ways you know if
you're starting a company you don't
really care that somebody's from Milford
or from Hartford if they're the best
co-founder and they can help you get
your company off the ground and you
really feel the chemistry it doesn't you
know no at that point nobody cares right
if you get funding you don't really care
where it comes from so the idea of just
really kind of creating critical mass of
people and making it interesting for
people to come I think is key we've had
developers from ESPN come to startup
weekend people from really not there a
series of people who have the same kind
of passions concerns aspirations that
kind of a cross section of the
population has in the entrepreneurial
world so a developer in ESPN might be
really really interested in starting a
business and not really know how so one
of the reasons that we do consistently
monthly events we have one called launch
Haven that kind of focuses just on
pitching and meeting people in the
community but also startup weekend
you haven which wasn't our idea to start
about of Seattle that created this kind
of powerful format for getting a bunch
of people together and trying to get
them in a space where they can help each
other with experience you know knowledge
work to launch companies in the end of
like a 50 for our format the reason that
we do have events like that is is
because they kind of create this space
to convene people who feel like they
want to do something in the startup
space and they're not sure what and by
rapidly kind of combining those people
and getting them to work together in
little ways roll up their sleeves they
start to get to know each other they
start to get to know who can help who
can't and where you know where to take
the next step so coming back to the
startup weekend point I think it is
really powerful we do it every year and
we do it because we get about 150 people
from the community who want to see the
pitches want to come out and work on a
team try a new idea and you might see
you know ten percent of the people might
be the same people as last year working
on the next big thing that they're
trying to try to launch so it's really
great great format and we'll do it again
this coming November cool but also I'd
say Tuesday's that make Haven is a great
place to start meeting people last night
I hadn't been in a while and make Haven
is this maker space that was referenced
earlier it's on State Street in nine
square and on Tuesdays we have an open
space night and last night there were
nine students from quinnipiac and the
electronic or digital media program
person interested in sustainability in
tech from who works in the city of
Bridgeport a few guys from Branford to
our engineers some of the folks from my
company in other folks from around the
nine squaring it really I think for the
first time to me that felt like this is
this is Connecticut gathering around New
Haven this is this is what the grid is
about this is what an ecosystem is about
what kind of things were people making
them yeah it's a good question we have
two MakerBot tues and
people were testing out 3d printing for
the first time there were the students
from quinnipiac were there to work on
designing an interface for something to
do with beer whatever though didn't they
didn't quite know yet I think brewing
was I think that they were there is one
of our members as got a brew a beer
brewing idea and they needed a user
interface for that brewing machine he
was planning on building funny how nine
people show up when that's the challenge
yeah saving the world maybe not as much
I think there's a real issue in
Connecticut about trying to find talent
though because there is so I moved here
October of 2011 and moved to Hartford
and you could very quickly see the
energy that New Haven has visa vie these
other cities and it just had draw so
even though I'm even though we lived in
Hartford we kind of we're looking to say
could be rent here in Newark because it
did have that kind dynamism and vibrancy
yeah and so there is a that's a real a
real draw and I think where we sit where
can I said anyway having statewide
responsibilities we need to be really
sensitive to the fact that we're not
putting all the cards into one place but
when you're looking at how do you
actually make a productive regional
economy one of things we know is that
cities really Drive rooms and cities
drive a lot of that effort mm-hmm so the
hence the hub structure in the end of
the hub model but it'll be fast me to
see what actually evolves because what
will likely what might happen is that
these places that have opportunities
that have ways that people combine
around make havens around launch havens
around and that will just draw people
who want to do more of that and you have
this na cumulation factor that just
piles up I think where I said what I'm
concerned about is to make sure that the
place is like Waterbury Hartford Avon I
also danbury places that were really
strong back than that 1950s 1940s they
have entrepreneurs there too they have
paid peep they have paid people making
awesome companies so how do we build
front doors so that they can access the
same type of opportunities inside New
Haven but
even take those back and there's a lot
of networks and connections so I think
transportation feeling like if I live in
Hartford I've got more friends here then
I've gotten in another state in Boston
so I i will just gravitate over on
somewhere inside connecticut rather than
gravitate to a bigger center elsewhere
so that's the whole sticky community
aspect is to say it is about friends it
is about peers it is about those really
kind of motivation interactions with
others and I think we want to make sure
that those people who really inspire us
we can we can have all those people meet
and it not be based on hope and chance
but now it's based on actually strategy
implementation intention that's a real
element of this yeah I I get a kick out
of the fact that that the best answer I
can think of to the question how do you
create more community I think turns out
to be the very simple answer karaoke
Erica's put together a couple of karaoke
nights that are really hilarious and
there's an som grad who started the
karaoke heroes downtown which turns out
to be a blast it's a new t-shirt that
that'll make ya heroes are better than
you're here right well I'm gonna pay
that to the left so ping pong is also a
component of this band and some other
entrepreneurs have done you know ping
pong right so I think this idea of fun
you know you can create a structure but
if it's kind of lifeless has no soul
nobody has nobody's really going to come
out so if you do you know get up and
sing karaoke i've been i've been
criticized actually for singing katy
perry songs but you know you got it you
have to take risks and as an
entrepreneur you know sometimes you have
to step up to the ping pong champion and
lose just so you can put yourself out
there it's an important it's a joke I'm
joking but it's an important part of the
process I feel like I want to be doing
these guys justice and I want a big
moderator if I didn't ask you to sing
like at least 11 very socks can we come
back to the wicking think about what
thought okay you want to say I think
this one specifically focused at Casey
but but you guys can feel free to jump
in with the state at the state level
what why entrepreneurship why does this
matter it seems obvious to me but yeah
what's obvious to me is not always
obvious to our government right so I
mean the short answer is for a long time
in economic development history was a
guy named David birch who started did
some research and put out the idea that
it's small business that really matters
to job growth in the late 70s and that
that meme has become obligatory for all
politicians to talk about small business
some interesting data came out in 2010
that showed that it's not small
businesses per se but rather young
businesses that are responsible for the
majority of jaguares so someone finally
got the age data and did the regression
and found that the correlation is or
that the causality is actually with the
correlation is with with age rather than
size that's interesting because that's
interesting in problematic for
Connecticut because the we are
over-represented relative to other
states in the percentage of our jobs
that are in older mature and bigger
companies so in a sense where we're long
on big companies in the state and we're
short on small younger and companies
that means that at at sort of
structurally were at a disadvantage
because young companies grow their
bottom line by growing older companies
tend to grow the bottom line by becoming
more
majora means shedding jobs so the
governor saw that and began asking you
know well what can we do to help how do
we blow on the sparks of the
entrepreneur efforts that are already
happening the state to help grow more
early-stage companies so that's the
state's interest is job growth and
revenue and I can go on on that topic
for a long time I'm going to stop and
turn it back do you might have had just
walk away I think it you know there
tends to be a little bit of a view that
so it's you know good for job growth
have small companies it's that's really
great we have a lot of big companies we
need more small ones but actually I
think the big companies also need small
companies so I'll make a little bit of a
plug for any large corporation that's in
Connecticut to support this ecosystem
project through corporate challenges and
programs like that whether it whether
it's talent finding software developers
locally or you know finding the next
innovative idea really the you know the
idea of an ecosystem is it needs to be
in balance there needs to be small
companies midsize companies big
companies and the reason that needs to
happen is because if there isn't a
balance in the ecosystem it doesn't
function well for anybody so I wanted to
put in a plug for that because I think a
lot of times we focus on you know how do
we grow more ventures and why is that
important its bits for jobs but actually
even at the top end of the ecosystem in
these companies that are more
established you know this part of how
they become innovative part of our
economy has worked in the past and will
work in the future is that we have these
different kind of organizations and
groups and entities that can solve
problems you're here to solve
environmental problems your part in the
economy is is huge and it matters a lot
to a big company and I think that's one
thing I think in our country that we
don't we haven't quite hit the
recognition that corporate America
really you know the top end of the
ecosystem really has a pretty huge
responsibility to support innovation
very directly people like then people
like our Connecticut entrepreneurs it's
a very important part of their own bite
not corporate social responsibility it's
it's part of them continuing to have a
business and not turning into a buggy
whip manufacturer yeah we've got a lot
of incredible incredible older companies
in the state of and I think about UTC or
pitney bowes I picked those two examples
because they've both got to both taking
sort of Derek's challenge and figuring
out how to how to invest in innovation
through developing earlier stage
companies so Sikorsky has developed a
partnership with the Stanford Innovation
Center where they put out a couple of
big challenges thorny problems that they
can't solve the one that sticks my mind
is that we want our helicopters to be
able to change color and at the touch of
a button so if you fly behind the white
snow-capped mountain want to turn white
you fly into a field of leopards I want
to turn the leopard print and Zartan
from GI Joe figured that out yes exactly
so they put out a whole bunch of
challenges and in a global competition a
couple of winners that came back with
the coolest ideas they sponsored them to
go into the Stanford innovation center
for a year where their co-working
amongst all the other companies there
and the other winners the Sikorsky
challenge and then Sikorsky might become
a partner might buy the company might
invest who knows what can happen but uh
that's that when pitney bowes has made a
similar challenge because they've got
all this incredible male equipment and
the mail system is at least changing a
lot and you know being dramatically
disrupted they've got those cool
technology encryption technology and
they've put a kind of a different
challenge saying we've got all this
stuff what do we do with it how can we
open new markets for this kind of
technology and we're hoping that that's
a pattern that starts to to take hold in
Connecticut that more and more of our
incredible big companies engage in that
kind of partnership excellent um I feel
really lucky I think we all feel really
lucky
our company that we've kind of come up
and been on this our current trajectory
under dental Malloy's administration I'm
not going to list all the benefits that
we've gotten or taken advantage of a lot
of folks probably don't know about some
of the things that are out there for
young businesses and and that they are
truly accessible and probably easier
than getting a loan from somewhere you
know some of the other places not not
traditionally not wrapped in bureaucracy
the way you might traditionally expect
do you speak to some of those I think
Derek you also probably have some
thoughts on this as well yeah sure I
mean the one of the governor's biggest
of goals coming into office was too he
called it reinventing Connecticut that
changed the state's approach to business
some history that I learned as I got
involved in this role and so I came
through the joint degree program with
school management forestry and come here
specifically to focus on
entrepreneurship and economic
development Green entrepreneurship green
economic development and got really
interested in how innovation works I
started a company with my best friend
Adrian or 10 right over there who's now
a venture capitalist and kicked it off
in the in the saban prize anyway and
then got involved in the challenge of
how do we make the state a better place
for entrepreneurship and I was lucky
enough to be drafted into the mole I
administration which is really cool he's
one of the governor's main goals is to
reinvent the state's approach because
we'd had a 16 years of basically the
same administration that had the first
so go to Roland had been very very tight
to the point where he ended up going to
jail with business his lieutenant
governor took the opposite approach and
said I want nothing to do with business
and sort of closed off communication to
the point where when I did some research
in 2010 I interviewing CEOs about how
the state could be a better place for
their company and other companies
like there's said I would just like to
have a relationship with the governor I
don't need help much but when I do I
want to you know someone to pick up the
phone and so that became a major issue
so new administration in 2010 Governor
Malloy I wanted to change that and
adopted a number of approaches to doing
that one of which was the small business
Express program which is sort of a
counter-cyclical loan program given that
the banks have bank loans have dried up
for small business the government
stepped in to fill that gap so it's
actually as long as you do it soon
enough and now they're just react you
can apply for grants and loans to
support a small business if you are
growing jobs there they also
recapitalised Connecticut innovations
which the state's venture capital armed
with 25 million new per year for the
next five years to be able to increase
their ability to invest in more and more
companies there I mean there's
international trade help avail from the
Commerce Department's state of
Connecticut office there is an SBIR
office small business innovations office
has din Connecticut innovations that
helps connect people to and they've got
a great internship program connecting
people to early-stage companies they've
got a go/no-go technology assessment
tool they can do they the main things
that they help you apply as a company
apply for an SBIR grant which is a
two-stage innovation grant from the
federal government and they'll help put
together your program there are it's
only a very small fraction of the kinds
of help from the state that are
available state help is not necessarily
the most important help there's lots of
other kinds of assistance mentorship
investment education that you can get
from lots of different players but
this effort admission because it some
effort is a part of that effort to try
to connect all of those different
resources that exist and make the
pathways easier for entrepreneurs to
figure out what's appropriate for them
and then find their way to those things
that's good I'll just build on that for
a second I mean one of the things that
as Casey's going through that list
there's a lot of stuff out there so one
of the things we hear from entrepreneurs
a lot is it's really hard to actually
navigate and find the right path to get
to where that resources especially
figure out what's the right support for
me right now and so one of the major
pieces of this whole project is called
growth company advising and so that's a
fancy term we've given to someone who
sits in every single innovation hub who
actually works with a company in a way a
social worker works with client really
taking ownership for that company's
success and and Enzo in new haven the
partners Rohit Sharma who works out of
the Economic Development Corporation and
so r 0 hits here we've got two people
and Stanford people in Hartford and
stores and one of the things we've
learned is that unlike other states and
other programs other programs are really
narrowly defined on defining that
program if it's a loan up consuming
opportunity you would apply for a loan
and then once a once a those funds are
granted that a loan officer doesn't take
a lot of time to understand what else
that company needs and so having someone
who's really looking holistically at
that firm is a really important element
that I think is really really
differentiates this program from some
other opportunities that are out there
Derek I'll just yeah no that's a great a
great point to mention and I guess the
follow-on to that is that a lot of the
tools that Ben was talking about in case
you were talking about coming from the
state that the this growth company
advisor might direct companies and they
really fall into five categories and
they're really the bread and butter of
what these hubs are trying to deliver
entrepreneurs face usually common
obstacles in about five areas one is
finding capital
and in different stages small capital to
big capital talent whether it's an
engineer mechanical engineer a software
developer somebody who can sell your
product talents really important finding
mentors and education is really key
community is obviously very important
and the last one might not sound quite
obvious as space you know not in a
commercial real estate sense but we've
all we all know the story of the
entrepreneur that started in the garage
and you know garage is a really bad
place to start a business in my opinion
an attic is as well it's very isolating
actually they you know we're starting to
see finally that entrepreneurship is
kind of owning up to the fact that
there's their issues of depression and
all kinds of problems with being
isolated and and and kind of starved
from community so actually one of the
reasons that we focus on community is
that you know getting out of the garage
getting out of the Attic puts you if you
can get to a co-working space if you can
find a place like make haven where you
can tinker with your idea and you can
sit and talk to Ben about the fact that
you have been eating ramen noodles for
the last two weeks and that actually is
surprisingly important to this whole
equation so these five tools that that I
just mentioned these obstacles each of
the hub's has as tools that solve these
problems for entrepreneurs and I'll just
mention one of them that's really
important in there it money so adrian's
over there he's a venture capitalist but
he wants to see you do something
worthwhile before he's going to you know
invest money in your company and you are
sitting there saying well great but how
do I build something worthwhile without
the money so a state program that is
really fantastic is this program called
the innovation voucher program so you're
starting out you need to find some kind
of prototype in capital some kind of R&D
capital you can access a
ten-thousand-dollar grant you can do it
quickly you don't have to go through a
lot of red tape and once you've gotten
that 10 that 10k you work with a service
provider who can't use an expert in
whatever field you're trying to rd in
and bam you've got some product you can
take it to Adrienne and say here you go
dude we delivered give us the series a
funding let's go so I mean obviously low
percentage scenario that will happen but
but the point is that one of the really
great programs and thoughtful programs
that the state is put in place is just
you know like a micro grant to get you
started doesn't take a lot of time to
get it going doesn't take a lot of time
for you to start accessing that capital
but can prove really really fruitful
when it comes to actually getting to the
later stage of the process so so it's a
plug for one program yeah that's that's
great i want i want to hear about some
more of those i have this friend um she
worked in a hotel in New Haven she did a
great job as an employee of the hotel
she had some ideas for a business and I
was the friend who told her to quit her
day job she did that she created another
business you know I think it's it's
sustainable but she's looking at the
next thing she's capable she's got a
great idea she wants to start if it's
kind of related to that she wants to
start a food incubator kitchen I think
she needs funding I think she needs
guidance she's one person she has
experience in that industry but she's
going to need need support what can you
guys do for her you know using that as
an anecdote how do we how do we help
that you know this individual it may not
because it may not be a business that
ever gets denser funding right but it's
a business that might launch the next
shake shack right and so it could be
vital to to this ecosystem that we're
trying to create so how do we help those
little guys that keep the rest of the
world you know our worlds exciting I was
actually going to reply karaoke is the
answer but I might have to sing if I
bring the school ring
up again I might be forced to do a
little beatboxing yeah so you know for I
mentioned it before I think you know
everything comes down to me in this
world to kind of a one-on-one
relationship so the role of this growth
company advisor is there but really
anybody who's involved in the hub
whether it's been you know Casey and
people at the state level or local
entrepreneurs are really you know here
to get that person to the right person
who can help them yeah so at the end of
the day whether or not you know your
friend talks to you about it and you
bump them over or whether they come to
us directly it doesn't really matter but
we want to sit down and kind of unpack
where are you with your business so
entrepreneurs are not kind of monolithic
any more than corporations are so some
people have got an idea not very well
fleshed out but you know has some
promise some people have something
that's very well-defined they've spent
their own money to prototype or they've
built something or software developer so
you really can't kind of apply any
hard-and-fast rules to what people are
going to need when they walk in the door
so that first few sets of conversations
are really important to understanding is
this a person who really needs to be
hooked up with somebody like Ben who's
done something in the same industry
before who can learn and be inspired
from an entrepreneur or do they need an
innovation voucher do they need a mentor
do they really need a technical
co-founder to get their idea off the
ground these are all things that the hub
can do for an entrepreneur but they
can't we can't do any of them until we
sit down and talk about with the
entrepreneur what what they're they're
doing and I think it's so I think a lot
about the kind of values that that make
a great ecosystem and one of them is
being honest so sometimes an
entrepreneur comes in and thanks look I
need to have a technical co-founder for
my business I need an army of software
developers or I need a lab space if I
could just get this or if I could just
get a million dollars of money from
Adrienne this thing would be in the bag
and you know that's not always true the
entrepreneurs sometimes deluding
themselves I've been there myself myself
actually and so it's really important
that not that someone tells you what you
want to hear but
that when they sit down with you they
say look based on my experience you
don't need any of that money until you
can figure out your business model and
how you're going to make this thing
sustainable and that's the first
question you need to really map out so
don't bother to engage a software
development company don't bother to you
know try to hire somebody just figure
out this one problem and then let's take
it from there so again focus is on this
first conversation and that might again
sound like a platitude but it really it
really isn't I think at the end of the
day Casey said it best earlier on you
know building a venture is all about
kind of a series of people knocking an
idea around and figuring out how to make
it work putting themselves in harm's way
in many cases and getting it off the
ground so it really does come down to
relationships and having conversations
that are really honest but come from you
know a place where you want to help the
person you're not yeah just trying to be
mean but you're trying to be honest and
get them on the right track so that's
that's my explanation of the process
maybe you can add yeah i mean there tim
has worked with all the participants of
this whole system to map out a to create
a real system of it so it's not
haphazard and there's a system in which
you can go to the website CT next com
fill out an assessment form that takes
about half an hour and then someone in
Derek shop or on the other shops
wherever you are in the state will look
it over get in touch with you with some
initial help and then if if you're the
kind of company with kind of or you've
got the kind of idea that can really
scale or engage with you at a deeper
level and figure out all the ways that
that we can be of help but I think the
the two answers are go to CT next calm
and find an assessment or just talk to
Derek or Tim myself we'll leave our
information here and take it on a
case-by-case basis I think one of the
other things so after that whole process
there's an action plan that gets
developed and so the a lot of this comes
out of what is the action plan for your
company what
next step what's other vision and that's
let's map ourselves backwards from that
point I think the example about the food
kitchen is interesting because it really
gets to the point that kind of kid is a
small state where 33 million people
cities are bigger than our state is and
so part of this whole project is saying
maybe the right person for that friend
to connect to is actually living
somewhere else and they're not in the
nine square area they're not in the New
Haven area how do we find them and so
another element of this is being able to
connect that persons that that person's
very specific needs to potentially the
right mentor the right the right coach
the right sector expert who's living in
st. norwalk or Norfolk or some place
that they wouldn't just never connect
with him about mm-hmm so Derek would
send a note to a Rohit the growth
advisor would send a note to a growth
advisor in another part of the state who
would have access to that person who has
that act that expertise and that's a
real piece of it and so I talked about
taking a taking chance out of it and
really trying to say well that's that's
great well I'm thinking now see click
fix you you want to get someplace with a
single click so how do we have the least
amount of clicks the least amount of
steps to get to the right support right
and it's really about that right Oh
connector with all of you guys can I had
one more tactical point yeah so this
third thurs every third thursday of the
month we do something called launch
haven in new haven and although there's
web form there are lots of different
ways to connect with us probably that's
the best catch-all you meet you know 50
people at one time get a sense of the
community right away so i would put in a
plug for that and i'm also going to
defer my karaoke singing to that event
so if you do want hopefully it does it
always have to be always has to be a
teaser so if you do want to see karaoke
performance by any of the four of us i'm
going to commit all of us to being there
on march 21st so come out and if you
know someone who who's an entrepreneur
who needs same kind of community have
them come out that's at karaoke heroes
yes what time 6pm is the beginning
then we'll go however long it needs to
go I know that you guys are all or some
of you are engaged in the saban venture
prize competition right now this
community is here to help you now at
given your current stage of idea now's
the time to connect and I know that only
got a couple months before the the pitch
in this room are up on the hill we're
here to help you get there okay I'd like
to open up to this this guy said thank
you you guys have all right excellent I
Anastasia a rock graduate of this school
and started a company here five years
ago I wish you guys have been around
these five years ago um I have a couple
of ideas one is I've been working lately
from home i'm totally sick of it I'm
looking for space so I'm going to follow
up with you on that but I've been
working in different libraries so I'm
kind of get bored and move around in the
kind of shoreline area new haven and
I've just noticed that there's a lot of
people hanging out in libraries working
away on their computers I don't see many
books being read and I wonder if I'm
you've thought about outreach to get
people from the library kind of world
into what you want to do and connecting
with them just an idea and you know as
it happens I was sitting next to someone
on a plane to dallas that he was ahead
of the public library in dallas texas
right and he was saying how they've been
using their library space for exactly
this sort of hub like purposes because
they see that there's a need in the
community and they want to encourage
entrepreneurship but it sort of opened
up this whole idea for me of like using
this space that's often really good
connecticut has great small public
libraries everywhere so that was just
one thought i had for you if you had any
if you've thought of that as well i'd be
curious i had another idea but that's it
for now i can't remember it sorry does
the state do marketing and for these
ecosystems in the public libraries in
the lifestyle that so in the libraries
know so that's a wonderful thought
because what coffee shops as well are
places that people hang out at
so what we have learned is that
entrepreneurs hang out online and so we
would not take out a lot of a lot of
print advertising we wouldn't take out a
lot of kind of TV advertising but it
really is about going to where they are
and what our researchers showed is is
that it's on linkedin its Facebook it's
on blogs but I think I I think to your
point there is an element about reaching
out to people who are really at that
early stage and they're still doing neat
things but they could use some other
peer support groups and so libraries is
fascinating I'm glad you mentioned that
i should also say my my um my friend in
chicago ran a pretty substantial
advertising campaign for his
neighborhood based business in the
chicago library system and had a
phenomenal success with that that was
like the number one marketing success
that they had mostly because there's not
that much noise and libraries
advertising noise and thank God but so
was it print yes really I think there
were bookmarks cool yeah well thanks for
sharing and are you familiar with the
grove yeah okay well thanks a lot I'm
William and a first year student here
the FES so you guys talked a lot about
the hub idea and it sounds like a pretty
good nice way to concentrate on the
talent and resources at one place but
what about the places out like other
places in Connecticut that doesn't
currently have to help today do you see
like a sort of marginalization of these
businesses and new entrepreneurs because
they don't have access to the same
resources that you versa it's a great
question and one that I've been asking
Derek lately and he's been to an amazing
job of reaching out to Waterbury handin
deep river and engaging with their
chambers of commerce and some incubators
that are around and sort of trying to
figure out how to make a network yeah
you're you're really on point I mean in
this in this process that the state has
has gone through I mean they
to pick as case you mentioned they had
to pick some kind of structure so one of
the things one of the reasons that we're
innovation hub is called the grid other
than the fact that the New Haven colony
planned out the the town on a nine
square plan called the grid that's one
of the obvious origins are a name but
the other reason that we picked the name
is that I mean I guess our belief is
that we're going to be a lot more
effective if we treat whatever we're
doing here is really just connected to
other entrepreneurial activities not a
replacement for it and certainly not out
of a statement that innovation only
happens within this innovation hub which
would be kind of misguided and I think
not produce the results that we want to
achieve so the grid idea is the way
we're implementing that kind of concept
is to go to towns like Waterbury talked
to the city talk to the economic
development people and say look you know
there's no reason the grid can't apply
to you the grid can't be a phenomenon in
the two counties that we we serve so
we've been going out to deep river and
hamden in Waterbury and other places and
starting to to just say what can we do
can we come and give a presentation can
we do a program here that we would
otherwise have done in New Haven and
it's important I think because we were
in deep river and we're sitting with the
First Selectman and he says hey you know
we have this incubator do you want to go
go see it we say well you know okay that
sounds interesting so we tried you know
six miles down the road following him
and we end up at a company that does
modeling and prototyping for covidien
and all these interesting companies in
this region never heard him before nine
person company sounds like they're
growing like gangbusters we would not
have known that they existed if we
didn't go and ask the question so you
know in its especially in our age I
think it's really easy to get lulled
into the sense of well if we blog about
it and we get on facebook and we you
know put out an email everybody's going
to know that's definitely not true in
Connecticut so this idea of getting out
and you know talking to people and
showing showing up you know that's half
the gate of the battle
in any in any business but it's it's a
really crucial part of what we're trying
to do it's hard but it's crucial I mean
I think what's what's happening now is
we've got phase 1 of this project so
this project launched last October of
officially so we haven't been at it for
a long time the thinking has been
percolating for a while the actual
planning of what the systems in the
process of look like that's still very
recent when you think about it I think
phase 2 phase 3 of this is really going
to open it up to be much more us much
more active in places like Waterbury and
deep river understanding how they
connect in a much more significant way
to the hub and come to these places that
have a lot more people and and
concentrated entrepreneurial action and
so we started we we have started talking
about it from a conceptual point of view
what does it look like to have a water
Murray in a much more active way as a
node in this network what it would that
mean what's the commitment from them
what's the commitment from us so I think
just right now where we're at is really
let's get the process right so we get
the entrepreneur supported and then
after that we can expand it out but it's
an ongoing concern to make sure that
right now they don't feel left out and I
think to Derek's point about the PR and
you have to reach out and this really is
about entrepreneurs in start-up
companies are sometimes young I haven't
seen stats on it but it seems and
anecdotally they would tend to be
younger but I know it's not by a lot
like there are really great entreprenuer
50 or 60 but when you get into stage two
companies and so those are companies
that are over ten people would probably
have a product in the market what have
revenues would have profit those are
business leaders and they could be any
age and so they're not they've got kids
that got families they're not wasting
time on Facebook and other things the
way that other people are that I am and
so there is I need to have a big
multi-channel approach to make sure that
we're come knocking on doors sending
them flyers doing bookmarks at the local
library I mean all these things are part
of how this word gets out
Thanks my name is Jeff what word i'm a
second year student in the joint mbam am
program between the school forestry in
school and management um you talked a
little bit about young entrepreneurs and
one of the things I see in in our
generation in a younger generation is
that it's a very mobile generation you
know what folks are not afraid to move
places and to to locate in various
places across the country so given that
what's your pitch for why New Haven or
why Connecticut is the best place for
someone to start their company right now
I go first yeah sure so I think each of
us will have a different answer I mean I
think the pitch that I would have to an
entrepreneur entrepreneurs I love to
build stuff and I think I get it at a
point where not only are you building a
company you're also building Connecticut
and so it really is an opportunity to be
much all up a lot more than simply the
company that you have but it's also
about building this much more larger
community so that's a key piece I think
yeah 2answers one is that we are working
incredibly hard to make this a better
place and you got incredible leaders
like Ben and Derick in new haven in
particular who are not only working hard
at it but they're really good at it and
they're really fun as well this is this
is a fun place to be in to start your
business the other answer is actually
looking around the room I so I came out
of this program as I was getting ready
to graduate my wife was in the program
as well and we looked around looked at
our other friends look to Adrienne
Anastasia looked at Stewart 2q around
the sea bay and of our 13 best friends
in the program 10 of them we're all
doing the same thing saying are you
staying I I was think about staying i
would eat and so it became the place
where we could stay with the coolest
people we knew and just sort of all
convinced each other to stick around and
it's been it's been heaven this is an
awesome place to be after graduating
still to be involved in this community
it's just heck of a lot of fun and
there's a ton to do and incredible
people who have made similar choices
over the years that the end up
connecting with and have made friends
with these guys Tim came in there's a
whole group of folks who have a lot of
fun and build really cool companies here
do you want to hear another version of
the answer or are you convinced yet if
you have another one I'd love you I i
have i have one and that is that yeah
there are there are big ecosystems that
are extremely attractive to
entrepreneurs and sometimes
entrepreneurs move there for really
really good reasons but one of the
things that's a special advantage of
being in a place like Connecticut or New
Haven is that you can actually know a
lot of the entrepreneurs you can be
sitting in a room and keep picking on
Adrienne I feel bad but you can you can
meet people who are in the space and
it's not crowded there isn't a ton of
noise you don't you're not fighting
against you know three other people with
the exact same idea you know maybe
Connecticut will be at that that point
at some point but right now it it's a
place that's really accessible it's
really we have a lot of great
communities it's a great place to live
so I think it's it's more niche and less
mass market and there's there's
something that's really powerful about
that in my opinion it's actually in a
lot of ways appeals to the entrepreneurs
desire to get the maximum resources you
know you're probably going to get more
resources here than you are in a bigger
ecosystem on average that's it's a big
flat I would say a big fish small pond
effect yeah there is some of that the
big the big fish small pond thing
without it feeling like the pond it's
too small I think you know for me you
start a business you're going to
sacrifice your current quality of life
for a future quality of life or a
feeling of satisfaction right that
you'll probably keeps driving for
forever because you're an entrepreneur
right but to that point why why should
you really sacrifice
quality of life right if you live in
Manhattan you know what you're going to
be living in unless you're coming from
for money or something or that a
successful exit elsewhere you know if
you're living in Silicon Valley you're
going to be living in a suburb you're
not going to be walking or biking enough
you guys have been to Google's campus
but as cool as it looks on the outside
it looks like every other pharmaceutical
company in the United States on the
outside you know for me I haven't had to
sacrifice any of my quality of life it's
only been surrounded by you know I've
lived inexpensively and well and walked
and biked to work every day for you know
five years I've made awesome friends
I've ate the best food in the world I
travel constantly and I am always so so
happy to come back to New Haven I never
get bored here and on top of that all
you know the rail line i'll take you to
Providence or Boston or New York without
having to be in New York or Boston where
someone can say now we don't need to
skype let's uh let's set up a meeting
and let's do lunch and let's do all
these distracting things that really
keep you from running your business so
that if you have to meet them you have
to get on a train to do it which when
you are focusing on your business is a
really really good thing not having
people walk right into your office from
the entire world is a great thing and
when they do in New Haven it's usually
for a reason and usually welcome them
and they can usually help you or you can
help them and it's not at the point of
distraction but but it you know at the
end of it all it's the food can I make
one pitch while I have a minute which is
I started in this economic development
world by taking an internship with the
organization that Tim works directly for
and it was the coolest internship
I've ever had I learned I learned a
tremendous I'm at and it was the blast
and I'm still involved in that with that
organization lap and yet we are looking
for new interns this summer and we
guarantee you a tremendous learning
experience a lot of fun and meeting a
ton of the coolest people in Connecticut
and the grove is your home base in
Connecticut so you would have an office
out of the growth that's also a really
great thing I also want to add one other
point about New Haven I could go on
forever about this and this is not a
uniquely New Haven thing that this is I
think unique to towns like new heaven
where you have this mentality that we
could be better right that we could do
things better that we're on the way up
and that we're not at some saturation
point or some like you know benchmark
that other people have achieved and that
there's like the entire community is
somewhat focused on self-improvement in
the way and and having that you know i
mean if that is the premise the
ecosystem right and you're an
entrepreneur in that ecosystem and
you're saying i'm here to create jobs
and i'm here to you know make my
neighborhood better i'm here to do
something interesting that it's never
been done before most people are going
to support you because they believe that
that holistically supports new heaven
hugely valuable